Everyone makes mistakes - even superheroes
- so, even though the characters you see in
comic book movies are some of the most effortlessly
cool in fiction, it shouldn't come as a surprise
to find out that the actors portraying them
are every bit as capable of making a fool
of themselves as you or I.
They might be superhuman on film, but they're
only human in real life, and human error is
an inevitable thing.
In this video, we'll take a look at ten occasions
in which bloopers occurred during the filming
of superhero movies.
We hope you enjoy this video, and make sure
you subscribe to our channel to enjoy more
like it!
Here are ten of the funniest superhero movie
bloopers.
Blade: Trinity
2004's Blade: Trinity was the final movie
in the popular Blade trilogy and it saw a
unique depiction of Dracula - referred to
as Drake in the movie - as the villain.
Portrayed by Dominic Purcell, Drake had a
human form and a monstrous form - and he transformed
into the latter to fight Blade in the final
battle.
Blade ultimately defeated Drake by injecting
him with the Daystar virus, which results
in him roaring in pain.
The overdramatic nature of the reaction resulted
in the actor playing him breaking down laughing
- which is a funny thing to see in full monster
prosthetics!
Spider-Man 3
Some people would argue that 2007's Spider-Man
3 was one big blooper - it really wasn't very
well-received - but there were some actual
bloopers from the movie that have surfaced
online, including one classic "can't stop
laughing" incident.
It's the scene in which Peter Parker and Mary
Jane Watson are in the swanky New York restaurant
and Gwen Stacy comes over to talk to Peter,
irking Mary Jane.
The blooper sees Tobey Maguire laughing uncontrollably,
seemingly for no apparent reason, over and
over again at different points in the conversation
between him and Bryce Dallas Howard's Gwen.
Hellboy II: The Golden Army
In the Hellboy movies, the titular character
- brilliantly played by Ron Perlman - is a
dab hand in the use of his faithful four-round
revolver, which is known as the Good Samaritan.
However, Perlman did have some trouble with
it on a couple of occasions.
In 2008's Hellboy 2: The Golden Army, whilst
talking to Abe Sapien, he failed to close
the gun in an attempt to reload it in his
usual nonchalant manner, and he even struggled
to get it out of its holster in one instance!
The Avengers
There's an epic scene during the final battle
between the titular team and the invading
Chitauri army in 2012's The Avengers in which
both Captain America's shield and Thor's hammer
return to the heroes at the same time.
In the movie itself, both characters seamlessly
catch their signature weapons and continue
fighting - but a blooper shows that wasn't
always the case for the latter.
While Chris Evans' Cap catches his shield
in style, Chris Hemsworth's Thor fumbles Mjolnir
and lets out a smile as he juggles it haplessly.
Iron Man 3
Remember that awesome scene at the end of
2013's Iron Man 3 when Robert Downey Jr.'s
Tony Stark remotely called upon all of his
Iron Man armours to help him and Rhodey in
the final battle scene against Aldrich Killian
and his Extremis soldiers?
Well could you honestly name all of those
armours individually?
No?
Well, apparently, Downey Jr. couldn't either!
When he attempts to instruct the Heartbreaker
armour to assist the Red Snapper armour in
battle, he forgets the name of the latter
and simply calls it "Whatshisname" before
turning to the camera, making a funny face,
and saying "Red Snapper" when it finally comes
to him.
Thor: The Dark World
We now come to our second Mjolnir blooper
in this video - and this one comes from 2013's
Thor: The Dark World.
Chris Hemsworth doesn't seem to have much
luck with Thor's iconic hammer, as this scene
proves.
It comes after Odin orders Thor not to leave
Asgard, but he attempts to do so anyway, so
Asgard's forces are sent to stop the God of
Thunder.
A group of guards attempt to apprehend Thor
in a doorway and, when the hero hits one of
them with Mjolnir, the head of the weapon
falls up, resulting in Hemsworth laughing
and swinging the handle around humorously.
Guardians of the Galaxy
2014's Guardians of the Galaxy was such a
fun movie, it must have been an absolute hoot
for the cast and crew to film it - and the
bloopers can only have added to that - so
here's one featuring Michael Rooker.
Rooker's character Yondu Udonta was walking
with Horuz - another member of the Ravagers,
played by Tom Proctor - when they walked too
far, reaching the end of the movie's set,
and Rooker lightheartedly shouted at Proctor
for causing the mistake to happen.
Avengers: Age of Ultron
This particular blooper is unique on this
list, as the mistake was made so many times
that it appears the people behind the movie
just gave up on the scene in question and
didn't include it in the final version.
It came in 2015's Avengers: Age of Ultron,
and it's Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner trying
to pronounce a bunch of scientific words and
terms.
We'll never know exactly what he was trying
to say, as he never actually gets any of it
out, but we'll let you have a listen for yourself
anyway...
Deadpool
Like the aforementioned Guardians of the Galaxy,
2016's Deadpool looked like it was a hell
of a lot of fun to film, and with hilarious
personalities like Ryan Reynolds on set, bloopers
were always going to be pretty inevitable
- especially when he had sex scenes to film.
In one such scene, when Reynolds and Morena
Baccarin are having some adult fun together,
Reynolds just can't hold it together.
His repeated thrusting causes him to break
down laughing, which subsequently results
in him asking for the cameras to stop rolling.
Captain America: Civil War
There's a scene in 2016's Captain America:
Civil War in which Vision, while aiming to
"turn Falcon into a glider", accidentally
hits War Machine mid-flight, which disables
his armour, resulting in James Rhodes freefalling
to the ground, hitting it with a bang, and
being injured very badly.
Tony Stark holds his limp, unconscious body
as Falcon arrives to apologise - but Anthony
Mackie didn't get his landing right every
time during filming.
In one instance, Mackie comes in to land while
hanging on some wires, but he manages to fall
face first into the ground.
Thanks for watching our video about ten of
the funniest superhero movie bloopers.
Can you think of any other hilarious bloopers
from superhero movies?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.